I think there's certainly some
possibilities coming up some of the
things that are out there are sort of
implanted devices they're not available
in united states yet trials may be
coming soon one is a balloon they you
know the old stomach balloon didn't work
real well but there's better designs now
they can be put in for about six months
and they cause people to lose about a
third of their excess weight quarter to
a third of their excess weight which is
about as good as the best diets out
there but this is really a simpler way
for patients to do it in a sense on the
other hand it has to be removed and like
I said once you remove it unless you
change your life habits the weight can
come back there's other implanted
devices that are coming along the way
also I think these are going to be
temporary aids but there are some
devices now that allow stapling with
from within the stomach so it's not
truly even surgery anymore we're talking
about going in down the mouth through
the esophagus into the stomach and
grabbing the walls of the stomach and
stitching them or stapling them together
to cause restriction to food intake to
make you feel full faster so it's not an
operation where anything is being cut
from the outside for sure and those
things are potentially exciting and that
they may have some permanence and even
if they don't have permanence and need
to be touched up they can be redone like
an endoscopy going down into the stomach
without surgery right now they still
require general anesthesia some of these
but but some of them don't and all the
others of them with time and refinement
may not require so it may be like coming
in for an endoscopy to just have a look
in your stomach here we just put down a
device and can put some more stitches in
or some more staples in and those things
are coming we're actually planning some
trials at Columbia with those things in
the very near future actually someone
just starting up now and so I think
we're going to learn a lot about this
over the next three to five years